antoine bonsoir quels sont vos
informations sur ces nouveaux tests bien
ce qui change par rapport au précédent
déjà c'est leur précision le centième à
près de 95%
mais c'est surtout leur rapidité
désormais en 40 minutes et simplement en
disposant d'un équipement de laboratoire
classique
le diagnostic est posé cette nouvelle
méthode conçue et développée entièrement
en russie permet une meilleure détection
et donc une meilleure prise en charge
des nouveaux cas l'entreprise qui
fabrique ces tests envisagent d'en
produire 500 milles par semaine
parallèlement il est aussi désormais
possible en russie de se faire dépister
son recommandation médicale préalable
sans ordonnance il suffit d'appeler de
prendre un rendez-vous et moyennant une
quinzaine d'euros plus le coût du
déplacement
on vient chez vous pour vous tester et
sous 24 à 48 heures vous recevez la
réponse par e-mail tous les moyens sont
donc bons pour dépister la population
alors actuelle 750 mille tests ont été
menés en russie pour 6343 cas confirmés
et 47 morts dépister c'est une chose
mais traits tirés
c'en est une autre tout comme quelques
autres pays la russie vient aujourd'hui
d'autoriser le début des essais
cliniques
un traitement possible merci beaucoup
antoine gayraud pour toutes ces
précisions